all right l.a county officials have
finally revealed the cause of tiger
woods car accident back in february the
county sheriff
confirmed yesterday that woods was
driving much too
fast at the time he rolled his borrowed
suv in an la suburb carter evans reports
now
on the questions that are still
unanswered
when he delivered the news about tiger
woods l.a county sheriff alex villanueva
made one thing clear about the legendary
golfer
there are some saying somehow he
received a special or a preferential
treatment any
any of some kind that is absolutely
false the sheriff says
woods will not be cited because there
were no witnesses as required under
california law
and there was no probable cause to
suggest this was anything other than an
accident there was no evidence of any
impairment there was no odor of alcohol
there were no open containers in the
vehicle and there were no
narcotics or any evidence of medication
in the vehicle
but investigators did not request woods
toxicology from the hospital
and no phone records were checked to see
if he'd been distracted at the time of
the crash
the suv's data recorder showed woods
didn't even touch the brakes
but rather floored the accelerator with
99 percent
pressure he was going 87 miles per hour
in a 45 mile per hour zone
investigators believe woods mistakenly
hit the gas pedal instead of the brake
and then may have over corrected causing
his vehicle to hit the median
and a sign before soaring over the road
and crashing
into a tree the primary causal factor
for this traffic collision was driving
at a speed
unsafe for the road conditions on
wednesday woods tweeted his thanks to
the deputies paramedics and good
samaritans who helped him
adding i will continue to focus on my
recovery
and family for cbs this morning carter
evans
los angeles so many questions still
about that crap and wood says he doesn't
remember it doesn't know how it happened
he's very lucky no one was hurt yes and
that's why he's able to to walk away
relatively speaking from a legal
perspective yeah
and we're all glad that he's okay we're
and i don't think anybody doubts that it
was an accident but i do think anthony
it does raise more questions
how do you floor it and it says that the
accelerator was floored all the way yeah
what caused him to fly what caused him
to floor
make that mistake believe it or not they
do more than a dozen people a year do
that and
if he did it that it's not a legal it's
a it's an accident that's what it is you
know